people are saying that the X6 pro has
the best smartphone camera in the world
so we're gonna go ahead and see if it
can destroy the iPhone 14 pro so right
here I have the first photo and by the
way they both have not seen the photos I
have done in this test I took them out
by myself and took all of these so you
guys let me know which one's better I
think I like the one on the right this
one is brighter but that looks more like
a DSLR shot a little bit more contrast
Lighting on the face less flat that's
true yeah it kind of gives the illusion
that there's a lot more depth yeah in
that photo so we both like the one on
the right now before video reveals it go
ahead and grab a piece of pen and paper
or your notes app and vote along with us
to see which one you truly like better
so let's see
wow that's a good start and it's
interesting that the 14 pro is really
flat like on his face and the Oppo has a
one inch sensor much more like a large
real camera this right here is an ultra
wide photo on both of them I see a lot
of kind of distortion or something right
here kind of stretched out uh kind of
like a DSLR would get with a lot of
ultra bites that looks almost not like
an ultra ride these both look almost
identical I do see like some little
differences but I don't think one is
better than the other these are both
almost identical they're both just as
good as each other I don't think one's
better than the other but if I have to
pick I'm gonna pick the left one I'm
gonna pick the left one as well okay oh
uh again very impressive out of the gate
all right the next one right here is
this is actually a crop oh and I won't
tell you the details until after you
choose so choose one I'm gonna have to
go for the left just for all of that
extra detail that you don't get on the
right yeah I do see more sharpening I
also see a little bit more aliasing the
one on the right looks more natural yeah
but it's a little softer I think in this
kind of a shot I would choose the right
one all right okay
well as you can see we have higher
resolution mode so 50 megapixel on the
left and the 48 megapixel Pro raw here
we have a selfie I think the one on the
left is two blurred yeah I agree I it
just looks kind of fake even though the
cutout is pretty good well I don't know
up here I can notice that the code is
kind of messing up yeah the one on the
right is a little more detailed with
that so definitely the right yeah the
right one X6 Pro
is destroying it man and it's cheaper
it's super phone all right this right
here is a telephoto Zoom shot now I know
that the Oppo has a telescopic camera
and this shot on the right has a lot
less detail it's very flat the left one
is definitely better that's what I'm
voting for and that is the XX Pro wow
wow that is a huge difference and I
really wish the iPhone had a 50
megapixel telephoto please this year
Apple okay this is I know it's a lot of
blur but portrait mode basically trying
to test out Edge detections and stuff
this one looks terrible yeah it's kind
of blown out the hand looks weird yeah
you would not want to use this photo at
all where the one on the right still
doesn't look amazing but definitely
better also the cutout on the hand on
the right is making it look really
really weird
see they're both bad to me the blur is
too too much on the right so you're
gonna go at the left I would go with the
left all right well left okay where's
the X6 Pro right what's Fortune all
right this one is a selfie my son and
wife well the one on the left looks like
it's a sunset with Sun hitting your face
yeah the cutout looks pretty good lots
of detail in the face and the hair I
mean I think the left one's quite a bit
better
that was my first point for the iPhone
wow yeah people say we choose the iPhone
all the time yeah all right this is
a very very zoomed in shot so I'll tell
you the details in a second so
yeah I mean they're both not great yeah
I would choose the one on the left even
though it doesn't really look like a
photo it's all blown out it's like a
painting at least you see the lines if
you need to capture something from that
far away you'll see what it is you'll
see something that is lots of artifacts
yes yeah so left yeah
well that is the X6 Pro 128 Zoom 20
times which they advertise this only
goes up to 15 and then I cropped in like
crazy to match it up I'm surprised but
that the iPhone still did that but
they're giving you from a 3X 120x that's
crazy Apple should do more than 15 yeah
all right this is my other son oh I like
that he's blinking yeah this is a 3X
portrait these are both really great
photos but a difference that I'm
noticing is that the one on the right I
like how this is kind of a little blurry
so he stands out from it as well it's
more in focus on the left I like the
right one I do like the extra warmth
like I saw before from the Sun on on
this side it's it's tough but I think it
is weird where this steals your
attention from the face so I'm gonna
vote with the right
the right one is the 14 interesting one
interesting difference here is that uh
the the X6 Pro everything's in Focus
almost like it took all of it and then
only blurred out the background but here
on the 14 pro behind his face it's like
layers his shoes in the front are
blurred too so it's kind of interesting
yeah layers next one this is a 1x
portrait the first thing that I noticed
is the colors like you Max mentioned
before the whole sunset colors on their
face it looks really natural looks
really nice also the trees in the
background the one on the right it looks
a little distracting a little weird in
the background where the one on the left
it's really natural and nice yeah I'll
vote for the left as well and I like
that I see the sun on the trees even
though it's blurred out I think it's a
better photo
and that was the 14 pro the iPhone next
one this is an ultra wide again so that
looks distorted but I kind of like how
massive that tree looks it gives it a
lot of presence I agree compared to this
one it stood out immediately so they're
right right the right one that is the
14. and another interesting thing is
that the iPhone does shoot a little bit
wider instead of the exits Pro which
kind of crops in a little bit okay this
is another 3x portrait wow I really like
the perspective and how the background
just looks big but it's blurred out
these are both really really good photos
um the main difference I notice is that
the right one the Shadows are more
prominent and natural but I like on the
left one how her face is brought up a
little bit brighter I also noticed that
in even though I think it makes sense to
vote for the right I like the slightly
blown out look so I'm voting for the
left
I'm still gonna vote for the ride
um the the Shadows on the face are the
one thing I don't like about everything
else I prefer the rice all right well I
voted for the Oppo next up we got some
what is that Pokeball
I'm surprised that the colors are fairly
close very very similar yes a lot of
other phones are drastically different
yeah I see a lot of natural blur in
these shots uh what's interesting is
this blur actually has some artifacting
in it here where this one is clean so
I'm gonna go for the right interesting I
was gonna go for the left because this
subject area
brights kind of
kind of um
oh right okay a lot of detail this is
really hard
I like the extra detail here even though
it's a little over sharpened I don't
like the blown out area here so that
looks more natural this is more detailed
I think I'll vote for detail this time
I'm voting for the right I feel like the
left one looks a little too unnatural A
Little Too Fake well that was actually a
big crop of just a regular main camera
photo next up this is a 1x regular
portrait very cute Eli was hungry I and
these are both really great the only
going with the right me too I think
we've been disagreeing for so long
finally we're agreeing I'm going for the
rest yeah it's very kind of cool toned
it was kind of weird so yeah but right
yep the iPhone okay getting a little bit
dark now I believe this is a zoom it's
like a 3X or 6X something like that
um immediately I really like the one on
the right I like how the sky is dark I
like how all of this is dark it looks
real the left one looks a little too
brought up yeah this looks like a
smartphone photo yeah it looks like a
DSLR photo it's definitely the right
yeah a lot of noise too in the left
that's the Xbox that looks impressive
very very good lots of detail another
portrait now got some different lighting
because we kind of have like a bluish
light outside mixed lighting situation I
like the one on the right I think here
some of the blur is messed up but I
think it's just too much blur in the
background kind of distracting compared
to the right one yeah I agree
good job I'm really doing a good job all
right this is I believe a 15x cropped so
this one looks a lot cleaner way cleaner
I know that in some of the other shots
sometimes there's a little too much
sharpening in some of them but when I
zoom in I want to see detail that's what
I don't like about my iPhone I don't
like all this artifacting so left the
left one looks really good it looks like
it's just enough detail to look great
but it's not pushing it too far like it
looks good
that is the X6 Pro it iPhone has a lot
of noise too you can just see it
everywhere all right
we got the Adidas tracksuit had to show
I'm going with the left for this one
even though I kind of like that the
right is more there's more depth there's
more shadows in his face but a lot of
the details in his suit are crushed and
I feel like the colors are just pushed
too far it's too saturated it looks a
little too weird I agree let's go for
the left and that is the iPhone iPhone a
little bit more natural in this case oh
here we go we got a macro macro macro on
both both did a good job but I like the
extra little highlights that you have
here where here it's a little darker a
little more flat so I'm voting for the
left yeah I feel like the right one it
kind of like mushes together in some
parts so I feel like I have to go to the
left too that is the iPhone 14 pro okay
now this is kind of like a detailed shot
kind of closer up kingstone Bible kind
of scary again these both look almost
identical but if I look super close to
the display I feel like I see more
detail on the left one I think that
might be true but one thing I see is
that on the corners the sharpness goes
down you get smearing that's a worse
quality lens design but here to here I
feel like there's also smearing on on
this one as well like up here maybe a
little bit I'm voting for the one on the
right left right right okay okay left
was Oppo right was iPhone all right just
a regular main camera shot right here
indoor lighting for this one I'm gonna
go for the one on the right it looks
more natural to me I think this one's
just too yellow
what I noticed is on the right one I see
a lot of detail in her hair that you
don't have on the left one the left
one's a teeny bit soft but they're
almost identical again okay
the right one is the iPhone iPhone very
interesting that it's natural I think
Apple's been tuning some things all
right Carl's Jr guys yep man I want a
burger yeah
yeah definitely the right one yeah I
think this has more blown out here we
actually have some colors I have that
color but with that said the one on the
right also has more aliasing oh all over
here so it's a tough choice I feel like
overall the right one is better yeah
I'll agree let's go for the right and
that was the X6 Pro I'm surprised that
it pulled back more HDR yeah on that
that's really good okay oh next up this
is a zoom shot night mode
night mode okay well this is brighter
like you can tell it's dark here but the
one on there is so much noise
and it just looks bad the left one's
surprisingly good that's the X6 Pro 3x
Zoom so they are doing a killer job with
that one all right this is another macro
shot oh that's cool super super close up
so it seems like this one can get a bit
closer I see on the right that the color
here pops a little bit more we have
something warmth in there and I assume
it's indoor lighting once again it's a
hard choice but I think this is a little
cleaner yeah I agree the right one
that's the X6 Pro oh nice all right
getting into some night mode
steering wheel shot which nobody does at
night man this thing just looks way more
like reflective and glossy nice it pops
out yeah and less blown out here at the
same time which is impressive yeah it's
definitely the right right that's the XX
Pro again man people were right
right this is impressive all right this
is a crop of a night mode photo I notice
a lot more
grain or something here maybe it's
texture where this one's smoother but
the text you can easily see I actually
kind of like that we have a difference
in brightness here and a gradient one
this is flat so I'm going for the left
this might be weird but I think I'm
gonna go for the right I
the right is the iPhone left
the six Pro okay you don't like Moody
like this now that you see the context
and what's causing it yeah are you
allowed to change your mind but look at
this look how the Apple yeah the HDR all
of that while maintaining this where the
iPhone just blows and this is flat I
didn't care that is way better all right
this is this is Paige black wow pitch
black I mean obviously they're right yep
the left you see there's something there
but it is yeah this you just delete this
the iPhones on the right
stacking more photos or do you remember
the length of time when they did night
mode uh the iPhone I think did it like
five seconds this thing I think was like
two or three and it didn't let me turn
it up I don't know okay you gotta pitch
black selfie I mean the player Witch
Project using the display as light which
they both do
the detail on the left is very
impressive
yeah but it also almost has this fake
look and I think this is the iPhone
because it it almost brings up stuff
under your skin I don't know like the
texture but there's like no detail on
the right though yeah you're right I
don't know I know and I don't have any
hair yeah look at all just that you can
see of this
okay I guess with this one you can pull
this down turn down the saturation a
little bit so I'll go for the left
that's the iPhone yeah next up this is
actually a 3X night mode okay
something is it is this even in Focus
like this one I don't know you can read
it pure cast still soap right yeah best
soap out there guys
yeah definitely they're right that's the
iPhone again so
the software at night for the stacking
it's doing a really good job
okay okay there's another one right here
yeah I definitely see a lot more detail
on the left one I feel like the right
one looks a little smudgy a little weird
I like the moodiness on the right one I
like that this pops stuff is darker you
could tell it's at night where this
almost looks like a date type kind of a
shot so I'm going for the right okay
iPhone was left X6 on the right all
right oh yeah another one another tough
shot here we know most likely what the
one on the right is just too dark when
you're when it's extremely dark so the
left
that is the iPhone again oh this is the
last shot last shot out of 33 this is
the last definitely the one on the left
yeah definitely the one on the left the
tree looks really natural you can see
all the sky behind it
yeah we'll go for the left all right and
that's the X6 Pro
and I mean look at this I this is
natural this looks like a DSLR shot you
have the contrast here it's just two I
tried to bring it up too much apple
needs needs more content and I think the
iPhone actually had a longer exposure 30
seconds compared to this thing was on
tripod mode it's probably like 10 15 or
something and yeah this just shows that
you have that one inch sensor it's very
large it's doing the shots quicker and
it looks more natural so there you guys
go these are the last shots if you voted
tell us comment below what surprised you
and which one got more votes if you
didn't vote give us a comment on what
you guys think about it you're close oh
man he's also the same no way the same
way I'm the same yeah yep we got the
same exact same
even though we disagreed on a bunch okay
Angelica you want to go first well we
got the same score so let's go at the
same time yeah we both had 17 for the
Oppo yep 16. for the iPhone I disagree
wow but I would say that the Oppo
and if we had less shots that were that
dark the opposite even more so that's so
impressive very impressive this is a
good camera
you can buy this for 840 bucks USD it's
a Chinese phone yeah uh but you can
bring it in and we also did a full
comparison to the iPhone it has some
crazy impressive specs really good so if
you didn't see that video right over
there yet go ahead and go check it out
we do a full comparison click the circle
above to subscribe and we'll see you
guys in the next video
[Music]
thank you